bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
une équipe de chirurgie internationaux
vient de réaliser une première en
matière de réimplantation d'une main
d'une personne décédée sur un homme
amputé il ya neuf ans en direct de lyon
là où été fait cette première la vie
chirurgien le professeur jean michel
dubernard
le coureur cycliste richard virenque mis
en cause par le soigneur de l'équipe
festina affirmant qu'il s'est dopé
refuse de rentrer dans le débat
il réplique de son avocat aux
accusations du soigneur hier ici le
premier ministre lionel jospin est en
chine pour affaires mais aussi pour
évoquer la question des droits de
l'homme notamment celle des droits de
l'homme au tibet trois mois après la
coupe du monde de football les retombées
économiques sont importantes ainsi que
l'adhésion des plus jeunes des enfants
dans les clubs de foot
la nuit dernière pendant près de 14
heures à l'hôpital edouard herriot à
lyon une première mondiale en matière de
chirurgie a été réalisée par une équipe
internationale composée de spécialistes
en micro chirurgie orthopédie et
chirurgie de transplantation
l'opération a consisté à implanter la
main d'une personne décédée sur un homme
de nationalité australienne qui avait
été amputée à la suite d'un accident
c'était en 1989 il s'agit donc pas d'une
greffe mais bien d'une réimplantation
dont le succès ne pourrait être vérifiée
bien sûr que dans plusieurs mois
voici en exclusivité les images de cette
opération avec les explications de
benoît gadret et jean daniel flaysakier
clint hallam vient d'entrer dans
l'histoire de la médecine
il est le premier à avoir reçu la main
une partie de l'avant bras d'un donneur
décédé
amputé en 1984 après un accident de
tronçonneuses
il a été opéré hier à lyon par une
équipe franco australienne pendant 13
heures sous microscope les spécialistes
ont raboutet entre le greffon il
receveur les veines les artères et
surtout les nerfs fibre après fibre
avant d'être opéré
clint allen disait son émotion
être le premier greffé de la main je vis
là avec l'humilité
techniquement tout s'est bien passé
le docteur va le docteur le donneur est
très bien on est très content on avait
de très grands sourires mais il faudra
de longs mois pour savoir si la marée
implanté peut exécuter tous les gestes
de la vie quotidienne professeur
dubernard bonsoir vous êtes chef du
service de transplantation de l'hôpital
edouard herriot
alors est ce que vous pourriez nous
expliquer peut-être par un schéma
comment ça s'est passé comment vous
allez travailler tous ensemble
écoutez on a simplement à partir du
greffon et due forme qui avaient été
prélevés chez un donneur anonyme quelque
part en france dont la famille avait été
informée de l'intervention totalement
informés et sur un corps qui avait été
parfaitement restauré à l'été l'aide
d'une prothèse
nous avons ramené le bras à l'hôpital
edouard herriot et nous l'avons préparé
en sectionnant à un niveau adapté à la
longueur du moignon qui persistait chez
clint ensuite nous avons préparé la et
individualisé repérer chacun des
éléments les deux principales artères
cinq ou six des principales veine les
trois principaux nerfs qui sont là les
deux os et simultanément une autre
équipe
nous étions huit chirurgiens de quatre
pays différents une autre équipe
préparée l'extrémité du boyau elle avait
recoupé recherché à ce niveau les
artères les veines des nerfs et les
individualiser et les repérer et ensuite
le tout le travail consistait à savoir
fixer les eaux puis à suturer les
artères pour que la reporte le sang
irrigue à nouveau la main les veines les
nerfs et nous avons les muscles les 21
ans domus on fait de notre mieux pour
que toutes les structures du monde soir
soit reconstitué et vous n'avez pas
destitué tous les nerfs on a reconstitué
la plus grande partie des nerfs et nous
avons su tu rêves le plus souvent à
chaque fois que cela était possible
fascicule particulière que l'on pense à
pelé ne soient pas contrôlés de mettre
bout à bout
les nerfs mais les fascicules nerveux à
l'intérieur de chaque nerfs c'est ça qui
a pris le plus grand temps en réalité
c'est une opération qui marque une étape
dans l'histoire des transmutations qui a
été réalisé pour donner le plus grand
champ sedan de chances de succès aux
malades et c'est la raison pour laquelle
sera associé à la fois des chirurgiens
orthopédistes des micros chirurgiens et
des chirurgiens de transplantation de
façon à part lorsque concrètement je
veux montrer c'est est-ce que qu'est ce
qui pourra faire avec sa main il pourra
pincer ou est-ce qu'il retrouvera
complètement l'utilité de sam un bon
moment c'est un succès technique mais on
peut pas préjuger du résultat
fonctionnel le résultat fonctionnel on
le jugera dans 12 à 18 mois
quand les nerfs les films nerveuse
auront repoussé et progresser jusqu'à
l'extrémité des doigts et lorsqu'il aura
retrouvé une sensibilité et une
motricité normale comme après une
section où une réimplantation ou
réimplante une partie d'individus sur
lui-même
à ce moment là on pourra se dire que
l'opération est un succès et il reste
encore pendant les jours à venir
la question du rejet nous avons mis au
point un protocole des minots
suppression spécial associant les
molécules les plus puissantes qui existe
est aussi des crèmes immunosuppressives
qui devrait lui permettre de traiter la
question qui nous inquiète le plus celle
du rejet de la peau mais c'est une
aventure extraordinaire en étant et tous
les jours il faut s'attendre à voir des
nouveaux problèmes à résoudre mais c'est
le prix de prix à payer pour faire
progresser cette opération est pour qu
elle offre des chances à des milliers de
personnes victimes d'accidents
domestiques d'accidents du travail
victime de manipulation de mines les
mine anti personnelle voire de
malformations congénitales deux heures
de trouver d'espoir de retrouver une
fonctionnalité et une image corporelle
normal merci beaucoup professeurs
le coureur cycliste richard virenque de
la formation festina ne veux pas
répondre directement aux accusations du
soigneur belge vit les voûtes qui hier
soir dans ce journal démontrait carnet à
l'appui que virenque comme les autres
avait usé de produits dopants mais j'y
reviens qui est actuellement engagé dans
le tour d'espagne vuelta
c'est donc son avocat qui prend le
relais aujourd'hui puisque le coureur ne
souhaite pas disait-il à 1 villareal
en espagne alimenter le moulin de la
presse reportage de philippe visseyrias
françois granier avec nathanaël de
rincquesen en espagne contre vents et
marées richard virenque essaie de garder
la tête froide sur le tour d'espagne
entouré de ses supporters le coureur
français veut oublier les accusations de
son ex soigneur on avocats s'occupant
tout cas des personnes qui me qui
m'agresse ou kim perturbé donc tous ceux
qui qui le feront bien ils auront ce
qu'ils méritent
ces carnets il existait selon vous voilà
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas je veux
pas rentrer dans des débats pour
alimenter comme j'ai dit le moulin de la
presse sur le fond de la sphère richard
virenque reste très vague
les accusations de willy gouttes elles
sont précises voilà ça c'est le carnet
tour de france 97 par là qu'à
l'intérieur de ce carnet se trouve la
preuve selon willy voûte que richard
virenque aurait pris l'année dernière de
le pays et des hormones de croissance
tous deux produit interdit d'y est le 8
juillet les 10 pardon pardon oui le 10
11 le 12 et la lui une une injection de
2000 unités epo
d'après cet agenda richard virenque
aurait reçu dès le 6 janvier 97 3 doses
de p&o 2000 au fil des mois
au fil des courses le programme
s'intensifie jusqu'au tour de france en
tout l'année dernière une centaine
d'injection d'après oui les gouttes le
dopage était planifiée médicalement
bruno roussel le directeur sportif
aurait instauré ce système à contrecoeur
les coureurs étaient des mandats et
russel voulait pas de trucs sauvage dans
son équipe et lui prennent pas de
risques de matin se trouvait à claquer
dans sa chambre alors voilà c'est tout
il était bien obligé richard virenque
victime d'un chantage médiatique c'est
l'opinion de son avocat qui n'a pas
changé sa ligne de défense
sur le fond une fois pour toutes
je maintiens que richard virenque m'a
dit ne s'être jamais dopé que je le
crois que je sais qu'il n'est pas mis en
examen que je sais que la justice à ce
jour ne lui reproche rien que l' enquête
disciplinaire engagée contre lui est
ajournée et qu'il a demandé raison
discrètement a tous eu jusqu'à présent
qu'ils ont diffamé
voilà pour 1997 l'agenda de 1998 est
entre les mains du juge d'instruction
il lui permettra peut-être de savoir si
quelque chose se cache derrière les
exploits de richard virenque encore ceux
des fonds publics destinés à des
bénéficiaires du rmi aurait été attribué
après un vote du conseil général de
corse du sud est avec la signature du
préfet à des clubs ou associations à
vocation sportive
l'information publiée ce matin par le
journal libération sur la foi d'un
rapport de gendarmerie principales
personnalités visées dans ce rapport le
président de son décor josé rossi qui se
disait indigné ce matin reportage
ajaccio agnès vahramian josé boulesteix
pour josé rossi c'est une fausse affaire
aujourd'hui président de l'assemblée de
corse
il dirigeait au moment des faits le
conseil général de corse du sud
le rapport publié ce matin par
libération lui reproche d'avoir attribué
des crédits d'insertion à des clubs de
football professionnels 7 millions de
francs sur trois ans détournées de leur
objet selon les gendarmes
ce que je désire aussi conteste le
préfet après les décisions unanimes du
conseil général aurait pu faire des
remarques contesté la légalité il n'a
jamais fait ni monsieur qu'aux effets ni
monsieur erignac pour 95 et 96
les préfets ont effectivement bien
valider ses délibérations du conseil
général que voici
mais pas pour 97 toussaint luciani était
lui président de la commission des
finances au conseil général à ce moment
là des erreurs comptables ont pu être
commises dit il mais c'est avec l'accord
des services de l'état que les clubs de
football ont été financés par ce que
tous les crédits d'insertion n'étaient
pas épuisées plus 40 millions d'hl
non consommée alors que toute cette
misère donc le préfet qu'est ce qu'il
avait dit et ans dont le chant ça qu'il
a signé à deux reprises le préfet donc
il a eu cibler une extension la notion
de rmi et c'est vrai qu'on sent stricte
de la loi
tout le monde est sorti du dispositif de
la loi et à l'époque même les
communistes dans l'opposition n'avaient
rien trouvé à redire
vous acceptez puisqu'il ya des gens qui
se sont réunis de différentes
sensibilités avec des fonctionnaires des
politiques et des services du
département et vous dites bon puisqu'il
ya eu unanimité au comité départemental
associations il n'y a pas de raison que
ça ne marche pas le rapport des
gendarmes est maintenant entre les mains
de la justice qui le considère avec
prudence une information judiciaire
pourrait être ouverte mais pas forcément
pour détournement de fonds
josé rossi mais aussi des agents de
l'état risque bien des mises en examen
sixième audience aujourd'hui du procès
de florence rey devant les jurés les
magistrats la cour d'assises de paris on
continue de tenter de comprendre
pourquoi florence rey et audry maupin
ont ainsi basculer en octobre 94 dans la
plus extrême violence provoquant la mort
de trois policiers et d'un chauffeur de
taxi
tout au long de cette journée ce sont
les familles de florence rey d'audry
maupin qui ont retenu l'attention au
palais de justice
le compte rendu de dominique verdeilhan
et avec peu de sous pour les parents
pour la soeur d'audry maupin le procès
de florence rey s'est aussi un peu celui
de leur fils de leur frère mort dans la
fusillade pour lysiane son frère à payer
ce qu'il a fait ne fait pas payer
florence à sa place supplie la soeur aux
12 jurés et c'est une mère bouleversée
qui se présente à la barre la voix
étranglée
chantal maupin s'adresse aux victimes
ici j'ai compris caudry est responsable
de tous ces morts et de tous ses blessés
je suis désolé dans la salle le silence
est total tout le monde est tétanisé par
ses aveux d'une mère mais chantal maupin
va plus loin encore mon fils était
intransigeant entier il n'aimait pas
avoir tort il ne voulait pas travailler
ce soir là dit elle personne ne pouvait
le stopper il n'y a qu'une balle qui
pouvait l'arrêter
cette incompréhension les parents de
florence rey la partage aussi tous deux
des peines une fille adorable sans
histoire mais réservés
mais discrète secrète nous avons été
ahuri dit le père j'espère qu'elle ne
prendra pas une peine maximum mais la
mère se fait plus précise florence a été
subjugué par cet amour elle a suivi par
aveuglement
elle a subi une mauvaise influence et
anne-marie ray conclu c'est dommage
parlant daudry florence rey esquisse
pour la première fois un sourire
seulement il faut véritablement tendre
l'oreille pour entendre le son de sa
voix
audry c'était un révolté dit-elle
c'était un idéaliste seulement face aux
regrets aux interrogations de ses
propres parents et des parents d'audry
maupin il y a toujours ce soir les
silences de fleurance frères
l'interpellation tôt ce matin de cet
homme et une femme soupçonnés d'être les
pirates de la route qui ont attaqué
trois couples en moselle depuis le 12
septembre
l'opération menée par quelques 200
gendarmes s'est déroulé de façon
spectaculaire près de metz elle parmi
les personnes interpellées certaines
seraient soupçonnés d'être mêlés au
braquage d'une banque
et puis ce soir trois personnes parmi
les personnes interpellées ont été
remises en liberté
le premier ministre lionel jospin est en
voyage officiel en chine et il entend
bien profiter de celui ci pour accroître
la présence commerciale française et
développer la coopération financière
mais il a déclaré que naturellement il
avait abordé la question des droits de
l'homme avec ses interlocuteurs
voici le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux à pékin roland sicard bernard
comme heures entre la salle de
l'harmonie préserver et celle de la
sérénité
lionel jospin s'est donné le temps de
respirer photo souvenir avec sa femme au
coeur de la cité interdite quelques
instants de tranquillité car pour le
reste il était surtout venu parler
affaires dans les rencontres officielles
il est beaucoup question comptera une
cinquantaine de chefs d'entreprises et
des voyages
la chine est le premier marché mondial
la france enregistre avec elle au
déficit
les patrons le dise il y a du pain sur
la planche
c'est un marché d'une ampleur absolument
gigantesque mais effectivement les
chinois sont très exigeants il ya
beaucoup de pays beaucoup de sociétés
qui sont désireuses d'y rentrer les
chinois le font payer d'une certaine
façon en tout cas des contrats ont été
signés pour plus d'un milliard de francs
d'autres comme le métro de shanghai sont
à l'étude mais il a aussi été question
des droits de l'homme ce matin de
dissidents ont été arrêtés pourtant
lionel jospin peut juger sur la durée
nous savons que en ce qui concerne le
problème des droits de l'homme où les
philosophies ne sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes le premier ministre me l'a dit où
les traditions historiques également
sont différentes
eh bien ce sera un processus continu on
évoluera positivement
en tout cas c'est dans cet esprit que
j'ai abordé ces discussions
lionel jospin qui a donc voulu montrer
que la question des droits de l'homme
n'était pas taboue et que le mieux était
d'en parler une liste de neuf n'ont été
transmises le sort du tibet et du dalaï
lama a été évoquée les chinois ont pris
des notes
mais pour le moment ils n'ont pas pris
d'engagement est permis d entreprises
françaises présentes en chine il y à
citroën sous la fin d'une coentreprise
une joint-venture deux ans après la
sortie de chaîne de la première est
dicté chinoise citroën installée a vu
anne va encore perdre cette année près
d'un milliard de francs
la gestion chinoise est assez opaque et
le réseau commercial quasi inexistant
dans l'usiné citroën de vue à nous l'on
va sortir un nouveau modèle de ces
hideuses adx spécial chine
on garde l'espoir de résoudre la
difficulté due aussi à la politique de
la maison mère française
reportage de notre correspondant à pékin
il avait le beige clair tristan le braz
pour l'instant ce sont encore des tôles
françaises ou belges qui sont emboutis à
vos fans pour fabriquer la zelnik
bientôt elles seront remplacées par de
l'acier laminé en chine ce qui devrait
réduire de 30% environ
le prix de la tôle c'est ainsi que la
chine qu'en soient les coopérations
industrielles transfert de technologie
maximum et localisation de la production
à rythmes forcé pour la zx au bout de
deux ans de fabrication 80% des pièces
sont fabriquées sur place
désormais les sous traitants étrangers
français ou européens ne représente plus
que 30 % de nos fournisseurs
avant ils étaient beaucoup plus nombreux
environ 70 à 80%
nous avons constitué un véritable tissu
industriel ici de fait avoue rano outre
ces 5000 salariés proprement dit la
joint-venture citroën induits plus de
3000 emplois dérivés les 10000 taxi de
cette ville de 7 millions d'habitants
sont des enix
pourtant tout n'est pas rose pour les
sous traitants car citroën voran à de
gros problèmes de liquidités pour bundy
par exemple qui produit des durites à
partir de tubes revêtu d'époxy importés
se maintenir à flot relève de la
quadrature du cercle
car citroën vo crâne est un fort mauvais
payeurs le retard de paiement de citroën
et de six mois en moyenne et en plus
nous devons payer notre matière première
qui vient de france 3 mois avant de la
recevoir donc c'est très difficile mais
il faut prendre notre mal en patience si
un jour nous voulons récolter les fruits
du succès citroën
en clair citroën finance sa production
sur le dos de ses sous-traitants
le superbe investissements ne parviendra
à trouver son équilibre qu'en 99 au
mieux et la zx avoue être l'auto la plus
moderne produites à ce jour dans le pays
sans coffre elle se vend mal car les
chinois préfèrent les voitures plus
prestigieuse la production de dix mille
de ces voitures tricorps démarre à peine
et laisse espérer de meilleures ventes à
terme si les sous traitants tiennent le
coup il ya certainement quelques
exemples où on est à six mois tel que
fournisseur acquis pour lesquels on les
regarde si vous enlevez on les remercie
cela de d'avoir confiance en nous mais
ils seront récompensés certainement
l'optimisme du pdg français se fonde sur
cette fameuse zx à coffre inconnu en
france pour faire moins de pertes et
vendre plus
il a fallu s'adapter aux goûts locales
et aux contraintes de l'environnement
la suspension
a besoin d'être renforcée assez
fortement manière à passer dans les
différentes inégalités des routes
chinoises
nous avons pour ce faire remonter la
voiture de quelques centimètres et
renforcer lés
tout le mécanisme de suspension et il a
fallu renforcer la commande de klaxons
si on voulait qu'elle résiste un peu
plus que quelques milliers de kilomètres
l'objectif de vente pour 99 et de 90
mille véhicules
encore faut-il pouvoir briser les
protectionnismes divers et variés qui
obère le marché il y enchaîne tellement
de microclimat réglementaires qu'il est
bien difficile de vendre son produit
sans crédit à la consommation par
exemple alors que les simples
particuliers commencent tacheté plus
d'automobiles que les sociétés et les
administrations
la grande-bretagne et l'iran ont décidé
de rétablir leurs relations
diplomatiques au niveau des ambassadeurs
sa décision fait suite à la déclaration
des autorités iraniennes
affirmant qu'elle ne soutenait plus la
prime de 2,5 millions de dollars promise
à celui qui exécute ray l'écrivain
salman rushdie explications de notre
correspondant à londres etienne
leenhardt dans un couloir des nations
unies cet après midi voici donc le
ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères et son homologue iranien
une phrase simple et clair pour lever
officiellement la condamnation à mort
prononcée à l'encontre de salman rushdie
le gouvernement de la république
islamique d'iran n'a pas l'intention et
ne prendra aucune action menaçant la vie
de l'auteur des versets sataniques
depuis bientôt dix ans allemagne russie
vivaient en grande bretagne comme un
semi clandestin ne se déplacent en plus
qu entouré de gardes du corps
sur sa tête un contrat une fatwa de 15
millions de francs lancé en 1989 par
l'ayatollah khomeiny contre l'auteur des
versets sataniques
un livre que tous les intégristes
musulmans jugés à leur blasphématoire
après cette annonce officielle l'iran et
la grande-bretagne vont rétablir leurs
relations diplomatiques mais salman
rushdie devrait rester l'un temps sous
protection policière les autorités
n'excluant pas l'acte d'une organisation
qui passeraient outre l'engagement pris
aujourd'hui par les iraniens
mais cette même route il vient quand
même de déclarer que cette décision
signifiait la liberté pour lui il vit en
clandestins depuis 1989
l'onu a adopté une résolution sur le
kosovo menaçant les autorités serbes de
belgrade si elle ne mettait pas fin à la
violence dans cette province la
secrétaire d'état américaine madame
hamelin
bright a implicitement accusé belgrade
de crimes contre l'humanité au kosovo la
résolution de l'onu réclame un
cessez-le-feu immédiat et l'ouverture de
négociations politiques pour un statut
d'autonomie aux qu'aux en allemagne il
reste encore 24 heures de campagne
électorale pour les deux principaux
candidats le chancelier kohl social
démocrate gerhard schröder
les sondages sont toujours incertains le
débat sur le rôle de l'allemagne en
europe après cette élection n'est sans
doute pas déterminant pour les électeurs
allemands
même si le fait d'abandonner le mark est
un symbole fort voyez comment une
famille allemande aborde cet abandon du
deutsche mark et l'arrivée de l'euro
reportage de notre correspondant à
berlin olivier lerner et ralf klingler
offer il est dentiste elle est
comédienne
ils ont des enfants beaucoup d'enfants
c'est ce qu'on appelle une famille
nombreuse dans le salon il y a depuis
toujours ce bocal à poisson qui pèsent
lourd ça doit porter pour les
collectionne et là maintenant je sais
pas ce qui va se passer avec mes roues
parce que même version
si on aura là la valeur monétaire on
n'aura plus que voilà symbole de
réussite de fierté aussi
adieu aux deux marques le compte à
rebours a débuté nous a permis de nous
relever après la vague est de nous
maintenir un haut niveau
on s'est habitué à ça et on est dans la
chambre de babette pas le moindre billet
scotché au mur elle a plutôt le choeur
grenadine pas vraiment le coeur gros
vous avez des économies à la banque oui
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire de
cet argent vous allez le convertir en
euros où vous allez le dépenser avant le
passage à l'euro
sûrement pas parce que ça sera changé en
euros tout simplement
j'en ai rien à faire des marques ça fait
combien euros
simple cinq ans c'est facile de calculer
oui
parce que c'est là la moitié
l'euro s'est donné trois ans encore
avant d'entrer définitivement dans les
moeurs
la monnaie unique furent alors vraiment
partie de la famille en belgique la mort
d'une jeune femme de nationalité
nigériane en instance d'expulsion à la
suite de brutalité policière provoque de
très vives réactions aussi bien du haut
commissariat de l'onu aux réfugiés que
la part de l'ambassade du nigeria à
bruxelles la belgique a décidé de
suspendre les expulsions de sans-papiers
et les deux gendarmes mis en cause ont
été inculpés de coups et blessures
volontaires
l'office des étrangers à bruxelles a
rappelé que le refus de la jeune femme
d'être expulsé cette jeune femme était
âgée de 20 ans ce refus était motivé par
sa volonté d'éviter un mariage forcé
avec un sexagénaire
le cyclone georges a déjà fait plus de
100 morts en haïti république
dominicaine porto rico avant d'atteindre
cuba il se dirige maintenant vers les
côtes de la floride du sud où un avis
d'alerté lancée jusqu'à présent c'est en
république dominicaine que le passage du
cyclone a fait le plus de dégâts et de
victimes provoquant des glissements de
terrain
tout le pays est en état de catastrophe
naturelle la trajectoire du cyclone est
pour l'instant imprévisible et des
volontaires de sécurité civile se sont
rendus sur place
l'enfer français aujourd'hui et demain
les anesthésistes-réanimateurs des
cliniques privées des hôpitaux publics
étaient appelés à faire la grève des
soins non urgents les vols dénoncer
ainsi l'insuffisance des moyens pour
assurer la sécurité des patients
concrètement voici le récit d'une
journée continue d'un médecin
anesthésiste il exerce seul à l'hôpital
françois rabelais de chine aux
reportages en f&a kg et josé où les
sexes l'homme qui tient cette seringue
appartient à une espèce menacée de
disparition du docteur nardi est en
effet anesthésistes réanimateurs dans un
hôpital qui dessert une population de 50
mille habitants est encore peu ils
étaient deux médecins après deux
semaines de garde d'affilée son collègue
ya eu un accident cardiaque
depuis le docteur nardi ne quitte
quasiment plus l'hôpital
sur les deux mois là j'ai fait environ
une cinquantaine de gardes sur les
solutions de garde
ça vous semble sain à la fois pour vous
et pour des gens que vous avez à suivre
nous effectivement ça passe un peu
pénible bon c'est surtout je pensais
avoir une sécurité effective membres
quant à part la sécurité je pense que la
sécurité allait là ce matin il ya trois
interventions programme il faut donc
jongler entre le bloc opératoire et la
salle de réveil
à peine sorti de la salle dr darby
n'aura pas le temps de retourner roubles
rejoindre la maternité
l'infirmier en salle d'opération
le dr harvey part donc à la maternité de
naissance sont attendus cela signifie
sans doute deux anesthésie péridurale
ajouté au programme ajouté si cela est
possible à mon nez mais quand même au
courant puisque on leur dit que s'il y
avait quelque chose d'urgent ailleurs on
serait possibilité de faire et comme un
fait exprès l'urgence est arrivé un
jeune homme qui fait du skateboard s'est
fracturé et luxe et la cheville il va
falloir l'endormir vous êtes agent sur
marc nardi passera très bref moment à la
réunion sur les soins palliatifs
avant de repartir pour le bloc
opératoire après l'intervention sur ce
jeune homme il pourra débuter sa
consultation sur la douleur chronique
avec plus d'une heure de retard alors
offrir ce bip c'est la maternité qui
appelle trop tard pour la péridurale la
maman a accouché mais elle en a quand
même besoin d'être endormi
car il faut pouvoir délivrer le placenta
il est 17h et le docteur nardi est loin
d'avoir fini sa journée
mathilde elle est née sans problème mais
quand elle sera en âge d'avoir des
enfants si rien ne change
la france aura perdu la moitié de ses
amis désiste
mouvement de grève à radio france
c'est-à-dire france culture france
musique
et puis france inter principalement les
organisations syndicales exigent des
moyens supplémentaires et la fin d'une
gestion autoritaire champion du monde
combien de fois l'at on répété depuis la
victoire de l'équipe de france
conséquence pratique tous les produits
dérivés de football dans les boutiques
de sport se sont très bien vendus mais
aussi les clubs et parmi eux les plus
célèbres ont vu enfler le nombre
d'enfants candidats à prendre la
succession des champions du monde en
quête emmanuel bex christelle bertrand
même si à cinq ans ne s'est pas encore
s'habiller tout seul on est assez grand
pour jouer au football
à marseille comme dans tous les clubs
français
c'est la rentrée c'est sur l'équipe de
france n'est pas championne du monde
tous les jours moi les inscriptions sont
démultipliés les éducateurs sont
débordés alors ils agissent avec fermé
j'ai pas si plus heureux comme s'il vous
plaît pas sifflé pas sifflé
barack obama même le premier jour le
foot c'est du sérieux
80 années passées alors voir grand
départ puisqu'il vient vous avez vu ce
que je fais travailler
ils ont cinq ans ces adorables ça c'est
pas dit qu'on va pouvoir se poser la
prochaine par rapport à l'année dernière
les inscriptions dans les clubs sont en
moyenne en hausse de 30% par manque de
terrains ou d'encadrement
certains clubs sont même obligés de
refuser des enfants il est encore trop
tôt pour savoir si tous ces champions en
culottes courtes vont continuer à jouer
en tout cas ils savent pourquoi ils sont
là
poudrier aller d'un nom à l'équipe ou la
vj dame à dalle dalle est où là dans
l'équipe vous l'avez dit dan avant de
jouer comme zidane barthez ou ronaldo
les enfants s'habille comme leur idole
on ne sait jamais ça peut aider
surtout les fabricants qui en ont
profité pour asseoir leur notoriété en
france avant le mondial
ce marché n'existait pas aujourd'hui les
ventes d'équipements ont dépassé toutes
les prévisions par rapport à 97 adidas
va multiplier ses ventes par dix le
sponsor officiel de l'équipe de france
compte vendre entre 350 et 400 milles
maillot à n'importe quel prix donc le
mieux l'équipe de france est passée avec
l'étoile de 349 à 3 199 francs
on en avait encore du stock crs sur le
sur le maillot traditionnel se mêla et
dès qu'on a reçue de mes avec l'étoile
on l'a vendu en rangs du latin 20
millions de gens tous les équipementiers
profite du succès français la fédération
aussi elle touche des royalties sur les
produits dérivés
dans les magasins les rayons sont
régulièrement dévalisés et quand on
arrive à trouver chaussure à son pied
on ne veut plus l'équipe et pour faire
durer le plaisir les annonceurs ont mis
les héros en scène pendant le mondial
plus de 98 % des téléspectateurs ont
remarqué au moins une fois le nom des 16
sponsors depuis chacun essaie de faire
grossir sa part du gâteau pour son image
de marque mcdonald's a choisi barthez il
a pleuré sur da final il est il à une
émotion en lui qui est vraiment
intéressante qui leur ont proche non
seulement des gens qui sont passionnés
de foot mais aussi des gens qui ne sont
pas passés
et pour passionner les foules il faut
être princesse au champion du monde
tous les magazines oui le football à la
une châtel d'eau a voulu tirer la
couverture vers lui ça vous fait ce
premier numéro qui a fort bien marché
évidemment nous avons monté nos ventes
de près de 25% à plus d'un titre donc
l'effet mondial a très bien marché
bien sûr tout le monde aimerait que ça
continue la recette est simple l'équipe
de france doit encore gagner mais ça
c'est une autre histoire
voilà qui pour les fanas je signale ce
livre d'eugène saccomano ces numéros 20
de football 98 une saison de football
20e anniversaire cinéma depuis hier le
film d'eric rohmer conte d'automne et
sur les écrans un compte de saison qui
achève le site les proposé par eric
rohmer ce réalisateur de 78 ans qui nous
propose une comédie sur l'amour au temps
de la maturité avec marie rivière et
béatrice romand reportage de pascal
deschamps et raymond châtelard c'est ce
que devrait occuper un peu plus de toit
enfin c'est ce que je fais je travaille
pour oublier oublier ma solitude deux
amis isabelle et magali à l'automne de
la vie
l'une est casé l'autre pas tel est le
point de départ d'un scénario pétillant
où la machination comme le raisin sous
les derniers rayons du soleil
lentement mûri pourquoi les autres et il
paye pas les femmes jamais lu les
annonces matrimoniales dans les journaux
moi je suis avec je suis son ami est par
contre moi je suis libraire enfin comme
je tiens une librairie je passe plutôt
longtemps à rêver et je me met à
fantasmer parce que je pense à lui
trouver un homme voilà je pense qu'au
plus value sans amour donc il lui faut à
notre et 45 ans ma foi c'est pas évident
de rencontrer des hommes donc je les met
une petite annonce membres sont alliés à
l'aide car elle n'est pas d'accord
cherche homme et
un aimant cherche homme épris de beauté
physique et morale je trouve à quelqu'un
pour elle que je fait gentiment et puis
on va pas les machinations sur mer faut
toujours comme ça elles sont toujours
consenti ça fait moment c'est à dire
c'est qu'un des personnages qui sont
menées par la machination à la salle
type lui plaît on pourra compter sur
jérôme r parce que c'est le traitement
qui est intéressant peu importe que toi
tu les racoler par annonce
ce qui compte c'est que moi je vais
remarquer sans savoir
rien de ce film après film
les héroïnes d'eric rohmer nous donne
l'impression d'être de vieilles copines
qui nous raconterait par le menu des
histoires familière à 78 rohmer
orchestre avec malice une nouvelle
comédie des sentiments fraîche et légère
à bobigny en seine-saint-denis à la
maison de la culture un spectacle de
philippe découflé souvenez peut-être de
celui qui qui organisa qui nous présente
avec beaucoup de bonheur l'ouverture des
jeux olympiques d'albertville et bien
cette fois ci
philippe découflé propose un dernier
spectacle beaucoup plus intimistes qu'à
grenoble qu'albert ville perdante ça
s'intitule charme humour et illusion le
reportage de frédéric bonnet
shazam un spectacle égaré comme cette
danseuse entre le rêve et la réalité
shazam un titre qui en dit long sur les
illusions de l'auteur 30 mandera que
magicien fait apparaître quelque chose
ça fait shazam ses marques et en grosses
lettres comme ça ça vient de sésame
ouvre toi
je crois c'est le abracadabra anglais
c'est comme dans les pays de l'est eas
hocus pocus
c'est la foire une espèce de formule
magique pour que faire en sorte que les
choses changent de forme magicien
danseur chorégraphe philippe decouflé 37
ans seulement et déjà le reflet de tous
ces personnages car celui qui voulait
être clown a commencé sa carrière à
l'envers c'est à dire par la notoriété
albertville 1992 à lui seul decouflé
enflamme l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
d'hiver mais aujourd'hui il est
redescendu de son nuage
dans cette ancienne usine depuis plus
d'un an il répète l'invention d'un
nouveau théâtre un spectacle qu'il veut
plus intimiste pour lequel les danseurs
sont aussi les créateurs
un travail collectif tous cas l écriture
chorégraphique maintenant c'est une
chose qui se fait en groupe
alors vous voyez bien outre avons
travaillé ensemble et puis je ne discute
on essaie de trouver des solutions autre
chose de les modifier en fonction des
gens des cordes et c'est tout mais
d'accord sur les intentions déjà shazam
nous les dévoile ses intentions sur la
scène deux individus seulement pour huit
personnages on est loin des grandes
parades désormais decouflé n'est plus
synonyme de grand événement dans le
kiosque
il ya un petit nouveau s'appelle
créamania ça parle surtout de décoration
et puis il faut saluer le 2000e numéro
de notre confrère télé 7 jours
voilà pour le kiosque n'arrivait à la
fin de ce journal je vous rappelle la
première mondiale de chirurgie réussie à
lyon la réimplantation d'une main sur
une personne qui avait été amputée en
1989 opération longuement expliqué en
début de ce journal par le professeur
jean michel dubernard qui était à la
tête d'une équipe de chirurgiens
internationaux dans quelques instants la
météo vous sera présentée par isabelle
martinet le mauvais temps progresse vers
l'est dit elle puis ira le point route
avec valérie maurice puis ensuite qui
aura envoyé spécial avec notamment un
reportage sur la mafia russe à zéro
heure 10 le dernier journal vous sera
présenté par bruno roger petit demain
c'est 1,50 dans les 4 vérités et
françoise laborde recevra le professeur
léon schwartzenberg à 13h vous
retrouverez carole gaessler rachid arhab
et à 20h béatrice schönberg alain dit
bonsoir merci